[Music]
in foul treatment news submitted by
ballin all four ends an animal rights
activist is speaking out against a bird
tossing contest at a County Fair okay
it's [ __ ] up okay Bri this time with
the animal activist yeah that's enough
as a dead chickens from like a grocery
store is it rubber to what I picture is
them throwing pigeons in a 20 that's
like a dove yeah they still don't want
to be thrown your throwing pitches is
not a beautiful sight soaring doves is
really beautiful but it's more like
you're just letting them go this is a
throwing contest and even if they were
already dead I'm sure they would have
killed them for the contest well this is
a bird tossing okay specifically edge in
rolling cotton no how do you roll a
pigeon are you I'm trying to be
open-minded
is it medieval times I'm not
closed-minded for the shoes you guys
will be mind blown you have bowling now
find out where this takes place can you
give us a hand
Portland no China all did you in the
United States no so okay okay
UK no Thailand some where are you mr.
Ling I don't think you might land it
Egypt you find the boys of the
archipelago no I want it is in Canada Oh
see the nice people there's white trash
in Canada so this is happening in Canada
and so they're saying that there's this
tradition at this particular Fair where
they have pigeon rolling contests where
like even kids are participating and
they're literally rolling the pigeons
they're saying that this is a special
breed of pigeon that likes to be rolled
known for their acrobatic ability oh
they're good at somersaults
they are claiming that they don't fly I
will show you a video okay all right
yeah let's so they're like chickens they
don't fly that's like throwing a cat off
a three-story building because you've
got they land on their feet
I mean I did that ball games off yeah I
turn there's no volume he's kidding
don't I love cats I love don't cancel
Joe yeah enter me and termine enter i'm
enter culture who's a kid he has a
pigeon in like a teenager okay yeah I
hope he eats it no no you just rolls a
pigeon and then they measure how far is
like so aggressive too so they breed
these pigeons typically for this war to
be their bowling ball yeah yeah yeah how
they discover pigeon rollin yeah that's
my question cuz like who who thought of
this idea to throw a pigeon on the
ground and roll it and see how long it
goes it's like one of those kids that
likes to kill things like with the
magnifying glass it's like some evil
little kid thought of it and they made a
whole damn thing out of and I want to
know who the Tom Brady a pigeon Rowling
is like who's the best yeah who's the
best you said that they could roll up to
two football fields
that's impressive like in The
Flintstones they like bowled with some
thing it may have like animals as part
of like like a squirrel or something
that wasn't that wasn't it no they had
stones okay yeah what listen Wonderland
they use yes
that's thinking you're right but how do
you not know that the pigeons aren't
having a good time though because the
pigeons are probably having a blast how
do you know trying not to vomit all day
but they're trained for this they're
trained for this and they're bred for
this pigeons can handle way more G's in
that's not naturally what they were and
so I'm sure that they're horrified yeah
it's called the herro herro fair and on
the website it calls the pigeons the
bowling balls of the avian world and
they refer to this avian world they were
meant to be bowling balls yeah they were
referred to this activity as pigeon
bowling at least once on the website
would people behind this are saying that
there's this misconception about using
the word or like there's controversy by
using the word
there's no misconception they're not
using bowling pins I think that's kind
of nice that's the part that they're
really highlighting saying bowling is
when you knock something down okay this
is rolling yep
okay cool so we made a [ __ ] mistake
it's still horrific well about at least
you admit they made a second thank you
yeah I will always admit that I'm wrong
I'm wrong and that is what really wrong
you just drop something and it just kept
going I bet you that's how they found
out like someone had a pigeon as a pet
and they dropped in they're like oh
that's like England but look how far it
goes hey let me try and then they try to
make it go further I rolled anytime's
holy yeah wait so do they
candy you said they can't fly I don't
that's what they claimed in one of these
videos oh you didn't even get it didn't
even try yeah he was just like am I done
here yet and the guys like no next
person yeah saying that they know that
they really love the birds and they're
not trying to harm the birds at all that
this is just like any other animal sport
like racing horses or dogs no because
unless those pigeons naturally roll and
roll around they did say that they're
like they're the way that they are
created in they're meant for ruling
that's probably a defense tactic like if
they're getting away from something like
they they can tumble and still survive I
don't think they're meant
we're doing jobs to the pigeons that
can't fly like you're not thinking about
they're like the Walmart greeters at
your jobs because they're not what are
they getting they get bird feed that's
their jobs but they would get feet get
tortured but you don't see and the
pigeons get a trophy that's what you
[ __ ] tossing is fine then you know
what they're profiting off of their loss
which is like some cultural
appropriation appropriation they're
appropriate in the pigeons culture I
will say this though I do I never
thought you could roll a pigeon for two
things all right slowly that's specific
I don't believe that I just picture a
pigeon what if your pigeon toed do you
still is it still appropriation yeah I
need to talk to a supervisor a target
team member someone who has some more
information
yeah yeah I don't think I can even throw
a ball for two football fields how the
[ __ ] can they throw a pigeon how no the
pigeon rolls by itself [ __ ] in like
friction and like gravity and everything
slow the pigeon down eventually he's
doing it's only work Joe Montana to roll
the pigeon he'd probably go pretty far
we used to roll those Rollie pollies
that's all I got guys hey it's if if
these guys are really into rolling [ __ ]
how come in on wall hedgehogs instead
because they roll that's true Sonic yeah
yeah Sony they just Chuck hedgehogs
instead they can also just roll
themselves what's up all for long
that's true some people can roll oh
maybe down a hill just maybe like you
breed two people to roll there's a
competition of who gets down the hill
the fastest and people just run out rate
that you fall it's a car it's a falling
contest and it's all [ __ ] funny
there's this people tumbling down the
hill hitting each other like there's
people that's like leaving on stretchers
and should they take it serious where is
that like in Germany use a lot of your
people's that's like the biking thing
where they they take a dirt bikes off of
off of like [ __ ] cliffs and [ __ ] and
they do it just to land and try to stay
on the bike but a lot of times they
wipeout and [ __ ] like end up in
wheelchairs and [ __ ] yeah
it's like a whole stupid they're meant
to they're meant to like Darwin
themselves Adam my favorite video one of
my favorite videos ever is the the guy
that the guy who basically founded this
sport of like just taking a dirt bag off
a [ __ ] rock like off a cliff side he
looks in the camera and he raises his
visor and he's like life's too short not
to go big guy to go big he shoves the
visor down he goes off a [ __ ] cliff
and he hits the bottom and rolls like 87
times like he died it looks like he died
he went to the hospital had to get a spy
[ __ ] check and [ __ ] and then like
part of this video like it's supposed to
be inspirational
it's him getting back on the bike and
doing it like like five months later
it's like what the [ __ ] this guy's like
a [ __ ] baby yeah it's amazing it's
good [ __ ] it's a hundred percent no for
me on the pigeon road yeah saying
something good out of it though but they
get a better fate than the geese because
the geese get all their feathers plucked
out of them and then make they make
jackets but if it was a chicken though
would it make it better no cuz chickens
look really funny you feel that sheep
then well they just share the Sheep like
support them it doesn't hurt them unless
it's like there's certain ones that do
mass production where I like it it does
hurt them and cut them and stuff but
like you know you buy from like a local
place they just shear the sheep and they
a big spider what about that y'all don't
like spiders right what if I rolled a
big big spider I like spiders they love
spiders they do in like animal life like
in the Philippines there's this game
that actually kalila was teaching me
about and as a kid she would go and
collect spiders and it where you put the
spiders on like a stick and you have
them fight like fight each other Oh
spider fights that's my story but this
just reminded me because I love spiders
Claire loves Y very if you can't like
like a black widow versus like a garden
spider right a sad no no
it was like a specific type of spider
that would do that would bite so you had
to find it but spiders a hell are you
help me love spiders because right now
our backyard in our front yard and our
entire house is teeming with spider on
your head you just have to be like okay
yeah I get bit by them and then I have
these ugly well are they bite yeah I
don't yeah well I would rather get
bitten by like a bit bit bit a spider
that has no venom like a like a daddy
long leg they can barely bite you daddy
longlegs and pee daddy longlegs are the
dead I don't care about those you have a
black widow I'm like no you should get
it out of your house like big fat the
problem is they just don't walk for very
long I don't think I think that a
chicken would probably wall for a long
time because they're shaped like a ball
already and they're cute and they're
very cute it's very Ewing animal like a
rabbit or a [ __ ] hamster just roll
them they look so cute
mmm-hmm puppies just roll one of my
favorite things to do is when my cats on
the bed I like to just push him over oh
yeah he's cute oh he likes getting
pushed over he like it just flops dude
he walked down he's like just go like
this for you to rub his belly yeah he
starts like rubbing his head on the
[ __ ] side of the way pushing him off
the bed no no he's on this and he's like
no and then you just push him over and
he's like oh yeah rubbing his head of
the sheets following that no no no he
plots on today no captive beans maybe
he'll do it himself too like if no one's
pushing him over he'll just go like to
like run their heads into you yeah yeah
dude he does that to make like a shoal
of it's by rubbing their face on your
face that's that's been oh my god really
loves me like nuzzling cuz that's what
animals my cat bites my hair if I don't
get up cuz like at first I'll feel
really cool I can't get up it's time and
then if I'm like huh just wanna sleep
longer then he'll start like going in
there like to start biting me he says I
hit me in my face my voice my earrings
off I'm gonna roll your
deserves to be wrong he uses his body as
a wedge to pick her head up from and he
makes sure that and then he'll lay down
at the spot where by my head was so that
I can't lay it back down why don't you
throw the cat I pushed him off the bed
before they come back he's like a little
alarm clock I hit snooze and then he
comes back ten minutes later and he's
like hey you ready that's what we close
our door and like we don't let our cat
go you have to look at her bedroom
carpet foxy and then he like pushes his
body on the bed I love doors so it
sounds like I tried that tip I have to
lock him in the bathroom
Arpit it's just like he's over there in
awhile but even then he does that [ __ ]
with the doorman he puts his paws and or
he's like yeah we'll do that for 25
minutes pull at the door like this you
know when there was um what was it
what's that when you lose an hour
daylight saving my mom so my cat would
wake my mom up the same way every
morning like yeah I am in a daylight
savings she he was by the 5:00 a.m. he
starts by knocking her glasses off of
this yeah I think
then he'll like climb onto the bed like
try and paw at her then he'll take a
cord and go I mean it's like she's like
I had no choice but then to get up
because it's so annoying
[Music]
[Music]